so I often get asked if there's a person
or company out there that that I find
inspiring who I think is out there
helping others and work in a unique and
special way and the answer is of course
of course of course one of my favorite
examples is Spanx founded by Sara
Blakely Sara is completely reinventing
how business works she's bringing this
balanced feminine energy into business
things like caring empathy patience but
what I love about what Sarah's doing for
her people is she treats everyone like
an entrepreneur entrepreneurs generally
start businesses and know nothing about
what they're doing and have to figure it
out along the way Sara tells all of her
employees pretend you're an entrepreneur
and pretend you have no idea how to do
this job and you have to figure it out
along the way and what ends up happening
is the people in her company are finding
new ways to do old jobs better because
they're treating it as if it's an
entrepreneurial venture like there are
no rules here that I can figure out how
to get this job done in a way that I
think is new and better instead of
worrying about have I learned the right
things Spanx has been a hugely inspiring
company both internally and externally
and I love learning from Sara and from
all the things that she's doing so Spanx
is a great example that's a company
doing things differently